Brad writers still had absolutely no
contact with MGM or Amazon about
Stargate and to be honest we're getting
to the point now where that's just
disgusting
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so once again I was able to exclusively
and first tell you the news that
Stargate franchise was going to be
kicking off with a movie since I
announced that I've had a couple of
other sources come to me one very very
close to the subject basically telling
me that yes that is correct Courtney
Valentini has been instructed by
Jennifer sulky to begin the process of
developing the Stargate movie and they
are working hand in hand with Mark
Fergus a penguin and Parker to do just
that I'm hearing rumors and very much in
the rumor category that legendary
pictures will be actually be producing
the movie they will actually be making
it and the Amanda Tapping and Daniel
Shanks will be appearing in that film
and hopefully the wider following
franchise because Amazon and MGM
completely expect this to become their
Temple sci-fi project they're losing
Star Trek they're not going to have Star
Trek in the future that's going back to
Paramount plus they need need a big
sci-fi project and they are putting all
of their eggs in the Stargate basket
now
I tweeted Brad Wright about this I asked
him what he thought about this news that
hopefully they're going to be producing
a movie and he gave me permission to
tell you what he said first of all he
says I'm far from legendary that's
because I called him a legend I actually
started the message with Mr Right I feel
I should formal to the legend but you
know it's Canadian
um he said not at all surprising
Stargate began on the big screen after
all they have the resources and they can
access a-less talent I hope it's good
now
I told you guys God over a year ago now
and again exclusively and first on this
channel the Brad right would not be
involved in the new franchise but nobody
MGM or Amazon can pick up the phone
they can't just give him a call and even
just as a courtesy speak to him as far
as I'm concerned Brad Wright is Stargate
he is the man that was there throughout
all three seasons he was the consistent
figure throughout all three seasons now
he developed these shows in
co-production with people like Robert
Cooper Joseph malozi so on and so on
but he was the consistent the regular
feature throughout now I don't know what
you think
but this smacks are really what happened
with the Lord of the Rings and Amazon
again
they did not pick up the phone and speak
to Peter Jackson now initially
apparently they were going to work with
Peter Jackson and then at some point the
decision changed and they just stopped
they never really spoke to him again and
he has repeatedly expressed his
frustration at what happened
now Warner Brothers are planning
spin-off movies Peter Jackson is going
to be involved so at least they have a
bit of respect for the people that are
actually important and core to these
franchises but Amazon
they just don't seem to now why is that
why haven't they just picked up the
phone as a courtesy and spoken to Brad
and again lots of sources have actually
told me that they haven't and have no
intention to so I I don't get it but
one of the things you have to understand
is that Amazon doesn't behave like a
traditional big Studio they behave like
a business they came into this world as
an online retailer they were going up
against people like Google Etc as well
when they began and you know they behave
in the same way and they behave like a
big ruthless retailer they do not share
information with people if they don't
have to and they do not care about
courtesy calls to people like Brad
Wright
now they do not announce anything unless
they absolutely have to and apparently
they hate leaks now I know because I've
been on the receiving end of several of
those leaks and I also know that several
of the sources I speak to have been very
clearly warned that anybody that does
leak to YouTube channels like myself
dial a gateworld however
will be dealt with now that would be
basically the sack potentially even they
could even end up being a case of legal
action against them if they did
something really serious or really
annoyed Amazon but that would be
unlikely it's more likely to smack on
the wrists and
the sack basically now they almost treat
the projects the movies Etc and any
leaks that come from them is like
corporate espionage
and I think that's the wrong way to go
us fans like to feel engaged with new
projects that's why you guys are
watching my channel is because you want
to hear what's going on you want to be
able to comment on it you want to be
able to then have that conversation
particularly when we're on lives you
know your comments come in we talk about
them we want to feel engaged and that's
one of the reasons why we love Peter
Jackson so much when he was doing the
original Lord of the Rings movies
because he did engage he did constant
little videos he did constant little
write-ups and comments and things and he
did loads and loads of work to tell
people how the development process was
going
Amazon hates that sort of thing and I
honestly think I honestly dread how much
information I shared with you guys is
even false information spread by Amazon
I don't think so and I'm very careful I
have heard stuff that I am pretty sure
is false news and I haven't shared it
with you guys all Chinese Whispers you
know stuff that is true but by the time
it gets to me through two or three
different sources
you know has grown I get these things
quite a lot I actually thought the news
that the movie had been announced was
Chinese Whispers when I got told it I
didn't think it was true and I told you
guys I didn't think it was true but then
it turned out it was but for me Amazon
I'm missing a trick they should be
exploiting projects like Stargate and
lots of other things that they do to
their maximum they should be engaging
with us the fans the customers they
should be trying to find out what we
want what we think now they spy on us
they watch us they watch videos like
this but they don't get involved they
don't talk to us or let us have a
conversation they don't put out bits of
information about what's going on in
development
they are very very secretive and I
really think they're missing a trick
because if they engage with us we've
engaged back we'd feel involved in the
process and we'd be far more likely to
then watch the end project
imagine if you will if they've engaged
with us loads more when they were doing
rings of power
for one they might have avoided a few
mistakes early on but 14 100 that would
have got a more positive reaction there
would not have been so many people
screaming woke woke woke there wouldn't
have been so many people screaming that
this is boring crap rubbish there
wouldn't have been so many people
screaming around which it cost rather
than the quality of the actual product
if they'd have just engaged with us like
Peter Jackson did they might have saved
themselves an awful lot of bother
but they didn't because they don't do it
like that
and they really are making a massive
mistake but guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think one about
Brad's rights being snubbed and Brad
writes comments to me I'd love to know
exactly what you think so again in the
comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also don't forget to subscribe to
the Science Channel or I do a weekly
Stargate video you definitely want to
see that if you're a big Stargate fan
also you can go to patreon forward slash
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of the videos
from Sidetrack and besides Channel go
first and for a small fee each month you
can see all of those videos way before
anybody else on YouTube and you get to
see it without the adverts
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
thank you